So, about a month into my daughter's kindergarten career, beginning of her being in school,
I was informed by her mother that her teacher was concerned about how she was doing in a
month into kindergarten.
You would think that there's not a whole lot that you need to know how to do, but apparently
my daughter was giving her teacher calls for concern.
And so, at the earliest opportunity, which was the parental observation day around Halloween,
I went in to observe the class and it was all very familiar and it was clear to me what
her teacher meant, even though it had been delivered to me in a really ambiguous and
hard to understand way.
I watched my daughter just be herself in this classroom, kind of blissfully unaware of what
was expected of her.
It seems all very innocent kindergarten and everything, but that's where they start training
you how to be a part of society, which if you're into that kind of thing, that's awesome.
But, you don't have much choice in this world, but so I'm watching her and watching her like
do her thing and watching her teacher get frustrated with her to the point of near anger
just because she's not jumping to the next thing that's being assigned to her because
they have little sections in the day or in the afternoon they have to work on.
It was very familiar.
A nice thing that can happen with having children is that you can see yourself and you can be
reminded of the progression of your own life through viewing them and I was brought back
to my experience being in kindergarten and I can see myself very clearly in my daughter.
We share a lot of similarities and I remember being handed rudimentary mathematics that
you're supposed to start in kindergarten and not being interested at all.
So not even bothering because it wasn't clear to me that it was like required.
It was clear to me that she was kind of in the same place and her teacher, besides rubbing
me the wrong way in a lot of ways, clearly didn't understand my daughter.
I didn't want my daughter to stay in that school.
I wanted her out.
And that could be just...
It's hard to say when you're dealing with your children because everyone thinks that
their children are God's gift to the planet or sane people do, sane people do.
So I wanted her out.
I didn't think it was a good place for her but I didn't think anything was wrong with
her but of course I didn't because I'm her father and it's very difficult to see your
children clearly because I would like to say because of the incredible amount of love that
you have for them but that's not totally honest because there's something besides the love,
there's ego involved because there's such reflection of you, you want them to do good,
you want them to be smart, you want them to be beautiful because you're smart and you're
beautiful and you dig it.
Or that's how you want to perceive yourself in this world and you want your children,
your offspring to have that.
That's maybe a little ugly but it's true and I think it's true for most parents.
So I do love my daughter a great deal and I love myself.
And I wanted her out of that school and her mother, a very fine woman, brilliant and beautiful,
we're partnered in raising her, we're not partnered romantically, didn't want to hear
me that maybe the teacher had the problem because she was beginning a career as a teacher
and she always heard parents talk about how it was a teacher's problem and that they wouldn't
be able to actually see their children and I had no idea how hard it was to be a teacher
with all these kids and blah blah blah.
Not blah blah blah, I'm sure she had points but we really, we're very, very good at disagreeing.
We can disagree very strongly.
I can see myself in my kid and I can see myself sitting at the kindergarten desk that she
was sitting at.
I can see the similarities and a lot of the similarities come down to an attribute that
is slowness, like a real slowness that we share that has been like frustrating to teachers
and parents and friends and lovers and roommates and any number of people.
For instance, it really can and often does take me an hour to put on my shoes and I can't
tell you where the time goes, it's not like I got distracted and started playing records
or something, like I can sit in the same place putting on my socks and shoes for an hour.
So can my daughter.
We can lose weekends just sitting on the toilet and if there's an apartment where I spend
time with my daughter, there's only one toilet so that's easy for me to see the similarities.
Thinking about how we see our children and how we see ourselves and our children and
how we want to see ourselves in a positive light, we don't want something to be wrong
with our children.
It makes me think about a moment in time when I was 17 years old and I was watching television
with my father, episode of Nova, it's like a science program that was on, I think it
was on PBS, I don't know if it still exists.
This one was on neuroscience and neuroscience technology and there had a guy getting prepared
for a CAT scan and being, receiving a CAT scan and it filled me with this crazy wave
of like deja vu but not just regular deja vu, like deja vu mixed with dread and like sickness
to my stomach and it was overwhelming and I couldn't stop thinking about it and wondering
did I have a CAT scan?
So I turned to my father and asked him if I had a CAT scan.
He said no and fell back asleep and then I couldn't get out of my head and I started
remembering more and more this experience of being a little kid and getting a CAT scan.
I finally went to my mother, asked her and she didn't want to talk about it and I persisted
and she admitted that I had had a CAT scan when I was six years old, something like that
and I asked her why I had had a CAT scan and she didn't want to talk about it but she started
laughing a little bit, which is weird, from where I was standing, kind of filled with
dread and having this repressed memory come up and finally she admitted I had had a CAT
scan and she told me why.
She said that I was so slow that they thought that I was retarded and I'd be given a battery
of tests to test my cognitive ability and the tests were inconclusive and they couldn't
figure out, the jury's still out, trust me, but the tests were inconclusive so they thought
that maybe I just had a brain tumor and so that's why I got the CAT scan.
I don't know if you've ever had one but I don't even like giving blood for a blood test.
I don't, this is actually, thinking about it right now, probably exactly why I hate
Western medicine entirely and will do anything to stay away from a doctor.
With a CAT scan, they have to like take your clothes off if you're little and you don't
want to take your clothes off in a room full of strangers and then they, this is my memory
so I don't know, they inject something into your ankle like an iodine solution and then
they lay you on a table and you get slid into a tube that sends whatever rays through your
body to look into your brain to see what's going on.
Totally fucking terrifying.
I remembered trying to escape, I remembered screaming until I was hoarse, I remembered
my father coming into the room and talking me down and I remember having my clothes put
back on and taken to the gift shop and my father bought me a book of animal limericks
and rhymes and photographs of the animals, all these animals from North America, black
hard covered book.
I remembered that book and I had it for childhood but I didn't remember anything about the CAT
scan after I left the hospital because it sucked that bad.
My parents loved, loved me, loved their children and that couldn't have been anything but
painful and frightening from my father too, you know, the whole situation and so I'm just
thinking about what motivated them to go to that extreme to see what was wrong with me.
So it turns out that no brain tumor as a child, just slow, I'm just slow.
I've figured out ways to live my life that it doesn't really matter as far as survival
is concerned and actually I've been able to thrive, you know, by degrees and I had to
think about that, it's so tempting to sing, so tempting to push it so past the time that
she starts playing and I have to improvise a song on top of it to finish the story.
I won't do that.
Just thinking about not doing that to my child, you know, having the good fortune to have
a child that's so much like me that I can take my experiences and help her, at least
in this moment, I don't know what the future holds and I don't know who she's going to
become, you know, but I can use my experience in a way to lessen her potential problems
in this world, which is what you ultimately, ultimately, ultimately wish for as a parent.
Her mother went to talk to the teacher a couple weeks later and came back horrified and wanted
to, but she's not a violent person, but she wanted our daughter out too.
So we took our daughter out of that school, she's now at a Steiner school, which really
suits her much better and we're both slow.